c'est un petit chalet modeste installée
dans le village de noël juste devant la
gare de tours mais c'est vite devenu des
succursales du père noël
et oui les enfants il faut savoir que
les cadeaux ne tombe pas que du ciel
derrière il ya toute une série de lutins
et de petites mains et surtout beaucoup
de générosité
ça met du baume au coeur et ça peut être
très sympathique et c'est vrai qu'il ya
un environnement au niveau des chalets
les les autres chalets sont super sympas
et donc c'est une petite famille et on
l'a vu des gens sont généreux on a vu ce
matin que l eau très très très généreux
les gens n'hésitent pas à acheter des
jouets neufs ou donner des des jouets de
très bonne qualité et cette année la
haute des restos du coeur est plein de
jouets l'opération relayé par france
bleu touraine est une réussite
la générosité était au rendez vous
chaque jour il faut donc désengorger de
chalais ils sont tous rapatriés au siège
de l'association
là ce sont d'autres lutins qui les prix
par catégorie
je pense que d'ici ce soir ou termine la
collecte on sera à trois mille jouets
3000 jouer c'est quelque chose de très
important pour nous nous avons 1200
enfants de moins de 12 ans restos du
coeur sur indre et loire et 300 enfants
de moins d'un an iront à faire des
heureux arriveront tous deux ou trois
joué chacun les gros jouet vous les
mettez par dessus
et puis de façon à ce que ça parte tout
est posé de toute manière on a eu
beaucoup d'établissements scolaires qui
nous ont aidé à collecter des jouets
c'est ça on n'a jamais vu ça sur sur la
loi on a 25 établissements qui ont fait
des collectes de jouets pour les restos
du coeur donc ça veut dire que les
enfants apporter des jouets dont ils se
servaient plus à condition qu'ils soient
en bon état bien entendu et tout s'est
joué là vont être distribués largement
tous ces jouets sont ensuite dispatchés
dans l'un des 20 centres des restos du
coeur d'un valoir à langeais par exemple
même à 24 décembre la distribution
continue on cherche le cadeau qui fera
plaisir
il faut faire vite il ne reste plus que
quelques heures à ces mamans pour que
noël reste un moment magique
merci à tous les bénévoles et à tous les
donateurs
enfin bon noël